all right so i know i know i threw you
a bit in the deep end there but you know
what i'm okay with that
uh because we come out of the learning
piece again so
have a look i know several of you
already have this which is great so
thumbs up to you but uh for those of you
who are like what's up with these tables
okay i'm gonna unpack everything so
let's just
start from the top i've introduced to
you
two logical statements that everything
else is based upon
and you can see them there as ping and q
it's raining
it's cold and we're going to consider
all of the relationships and
interactions between these two logical
things
okay so you can see up in the top
left-hand corner near my basic
statements
um i have two like very small building
blocks on top of that which is the
negations of these basic states and as i
mentioned before
i'm imagining a very simple binary
weather world
if it's not cold or fall apart if it's
not raining
i'm just gonna call it dry okay not
wearing it without any of this
equatorial
human stuff okay so when you've got pink
not p and not q you can see this
myriad of ways to combine them we don't
even have the full list here we've just
got
a whole bunch of them okay so let's have
a look over here
in the bottom left hand corner this is
one of the the simplest ways you can
combine
these two thinking that one logically
leads to
the other one's a condition for the
other so we've got if it's raining
then it's cold and you can see which one
is p and which one is q
so that's why the order of my
implication matters now have a look
closely there's another indication there
right i'm just sort of going
anti-clockwise around because
that's what we're used to doing in
complex numbers this one down here
um this is worth i ask you to get your
books out by the way if you haven't
already done that please do
when you can see this implication
running in the opposite direction
right do you remember we hadn't for this
starts with a c
i think it's a word we've used actually
for a long time we just don't
haven't been too technical about it it's
the con
verse right so saying the implication by
going
in the opposite direction so a really
common one that you guys actually know
and it's dealt with is what i said to a
long time ago
is pythagoras theorem pythagoras theory
how would you state pythagoras is here
a squared plus b squared equals c
squared we know what a b and c
signify their sides in a what
in a writing triangle so in fact even
though we would state i thought it was
just theorem as
i'm going to jump down right we would
state it as this equation
this is actually the cube in the p and q
of pythagoras's theorem there's
something that leads
before this namely the a b and c
are in a right right angle triangle it
doesn't work pythagoras theorem as you
know it does not work in non-right
angled triangles
you've got to um you've got a super
pythagoras theorem with an adjustment
factor
if you want to deal with non-validating
traits so there's
if this is true then this is true p
implies q in this case and you've done
this before right actually
like this right we know that if this is
true if you look at any
old triangle because you got asked to do
this in like you write exams right
if you can prove that this is true you
measure them you show this relationship
that actually tells you that you have
that so the converse of pythagoras
theorem
is also true you guys know that's not
always
the case uh a converse doesn't always
lead to
you know something that's true right um
i just gave you an example here maybe
you disagree with both of those
because you know you might come from
somewhere it's hot and rainy
but my point is that you need to think
about the fact that those are two
different relationships right
okay let's start to dive a little
further
in uh which one should i go to next ah
okay so
where are the equivalent statements i
haven't labeled them as equivalent
statements but which one of these
tells you that p and q are logically
equivalent
which one both arrows
like the arrows on both sides yeah it's
the two-sided error
isn't it right um and so we would say
it's raining
if and only if that means raining has to
lead to cold
cold also has to lead to rain does that
make sense
so we call those equivalent statements
now what else is familiar here ah
okay let's look at that negation just up
above someone more organized but to put
these cards in a
more useful order you can see here i've
got three cards together
right so if it's raining then it's hot
where does that hot come from is that
you already talked about it
yes the negation of q right so you can
see that's why
just literally interpreting that right
if it's raining is p
if it's hot is not q and then i've got
the implication running
right but do you remember this is one of
the things that we focused on on
tuesday's
lesson this negation
he needs to not tell you right
this was our result from actually
negating the whole
statement right this is factorio this
second rainy means it's cold you negate
the whole thing it's actually the
resultant condition right that actually
gets negated which was a bit weird we
were like
oh where does this go does it just go
through all the brackets it doesn't so
this is my reminder
before i go and have a look at these
tables any questions on those basic
stances make sense
yeah happiness so far okay here's where
it starts to get trickier right and
where we need to have a proper
discussion
actually what i'd like you to do is for
these tables and the cards that go with
them
those i'd like you to have in your book
because after you close your laptop
they're going to disappear right we need
to have a discussion about this
let's talk about p and q p and q so
that's here
sort of in the middle of the screen so
here is a training
q is it's called so when i say p and q
it's as straightforward as just putting
the word and in between there
but i'm a bit lazy grammatically so
rather than saying it's raining
and it's cold i've just said it's very
cold now this being this object that you
can see underneath
i'm going to draw up my own one instead
of my own eyes
this object here is called a truth table
a truth table it's called a truth table
because it's a table
that tells you what's true and why it's
not true right so you can see
up in the top here i think a jaguar pen
not p stop
right yeah hey nothing
cubed if p and q
are both being regarded as true
then i have to think about which of
these combinations of p
not p q not q are going to be
represented by the same
png
[Music]
okay now we want both of them to be true
at the same time does that make sense
it's gonna be raining
and cold simultaneously so that's why
you can see in my uh console there i
popped this one
as true and everything else gets
excluded because i i don't have room in
this statement for
either p or q to be false
the language there let me say that one
more time when i say p
and q must be true i'm not leaving any
room for the possibility
the pistols or shoes of so in fact
these are all excluded
right when you say p and q you're locked
into this top left hand corner
okay now uh what else do i have uh
yeah that's right it's fine okay now
this is why it's important and why i
think it's helpful to understand
what's the negation sorry no not an
artification yeah what's the uh
parallel result so if i change that word
to all some people last lesson kind of
like oh if i get a single word wrong
will i like lose marks in my exam
response or whatever
the answer is well just like in
arithmetic right if you just
put a minus sign there that doesn't
belong or if you change i don't know
a multiplication into a division it's
like such a teeny tiny symbol
you're going to lose a mark for that
well it dramatically changes the meaning
of your equation your expression and a
word like all
or and also dramatically changes the
meaning of your statement so you've
already got this probably
in your book because you've had a head
start on me but when we put down
p not p and our
cube not q here right
p or q uh we can actually include
many more options than this right if i
said it's raining
or it's cold right for starters here's
it's raining
right i did uh it's raining so
raining but not cold that's fine that's
fine uh
cold but not ready that's also fine now
we need to ask the question about these
two
right now i think we can all agree that
if it's neither of them
that's excluded by this you have to be
at least one right
but now this is where the language
starts to get a bit confusing and people
ask me this exact question not from
reigning called i think it was something
like
one of the first questions you had in
the exercise was uh bob
is correct and a is correct something
like that right and what was the
negation of that
now to understand what the negation is i
want you to answer with me
why it is that i put in
true in this top level
how can you argue that this has to be
the case
any tickers what do you think right the
other one says
um it's uh it's ready or code but not
though so that one's gonna be false
order
okay very good so we're kind of
anticipating this other table here
which has a different value and
different words that go with it i will
cover that in a second as you can see
do you have a different order yeah um
the necessary condition
for the statement to be true because one
of them is true
and since at least one of them is true
then it must be true
it doesn't matter if the second one is
true or false
interesting all right there was a lot in
that sentence just there and what i
really liked about that
not just that it was helpful but also
that we used some of the language we've
already been introducing here
so particularly talked about necessary
conditions right
so we say if p implies q then p is
necessary for sorry q is necessary if p
is true
right now we can actually say the same
thing of here if one of them is true
that'll lead to at least one of them
being true and i actually don't need to
worry about the other ones
i can say sorry about here right i could
say that the other one
too right if one of them is true
then i can see that you're going to get
this other one which has both of them in
it
also being included now i'm just going
to give you a really simple english
i'm going to try to make both things
down to simple as possible right a
simple english explanation for why
the word we're used to by the way is
inclusive right p
or q inclusive means i'm okay with i
should write it in i'm okay with both
right if i said to you hey guys you're
heading out for the day if it's raining
or cold bring a jacket
let me say that one more time you're
heading out today if it's raining or
cold bring a jacket so you look out the
window
i actually picked a terrible day to use
this example but this is my logical
status can be false as well right so
we're okay with that if you looked
outside
and it was both raining and cold
would you bring a jacket yes you would
because you're like well i've met one of
the conditions
so therefore i better bring it otherwise
it'll be cold and i'm going to be wet at
the same time right
so if you just see it with p or q
we're including both of them as well
that's a possibility
does that make sense to you yeah now
that leads us right along to the last
true table
i think the third and last one i'm not
going to draw because i think you buy
now about it right
and this is what jar was referring to if
i knew that color
if i say and sometimes i have to be
really careful because textbooks
will sometimes stick this word in and
you kind of you sort of blur over it
right
and then your sign changes the meaning
of a state makes it awesome opposite
a word like this
completely changes the statement or if i
said p
or q and i'll kind of give them both on
the card slot
but not both right p or q but not both
or if i said either p or q
or if i was like i want to be double
sure i had to be your q
but not both remember i said before p or
q
is just it's inclusive it keeps
everything right if you see either of
these phrases
this actually gets its own name it's not
in the syllabus but i think it's
actually a really helpful
name to have in your head because it
tells you what it is it's called the
exclusive or um any of you who
do now or will go on to um software
design the
abbreviation for this is x or x 4
exclusive
right now you can see the difference in
the table right in the truth table that
goes with this
i'm including p but not q that's fine
i'm including q but not p also fine
but if i'm like i don't want both that's
why a
false goes up here in the top left does
that make sense